even at this late hour on election day
the lies just will not stop being
uncovered from Donald Trump Donald Trump
has claimed not to know or have ever met
lots of people that we've later found
out he knew or had met this includes the
disabled Wall Street journalists Wall
Street Journal reporter that he mocked
met him a bunch of times this includes
the former Miss Utah who accused Trump
of sexual assault claimed never to have
met her just months ago though gave a
detailed story of his recollection of
having met her and now a recently
uncovered video shows that Donald Trump
did know a gambler who was banned from
New Jersey casinos for alleged ties to
organized crime this is the reputed mob
figure lob Robert Liberty who can be
seen in the picture were showing
standing alongside Trump in the front
row of a 1988 WrestleMania match in
Atlantic City New Jersey now you could
say okay well listen David they were
standing next to each other but maybe it
had nothing to do with Trump maybe they
just happened to be at the same
wrestling match well no because
according to laboux T's daughter Edith
creamer who also attended the event
quote we were Trump's guests the video
was given to Yahoo News by a
confidential source that discovered it
it appears to again suggest that Trump
did have relations with laboux T which
Donald Trump has multiple times denied
as I mentioned laboux T was banned from
the state's casinos in the early 90s
because he was connected to mafia boss
John Gotti then the chief of the Gambino
crime syndicate and separately the New
Jersey katika Casino Control Commission
levied a six hundred and fifty thousand
dollar fine against the Trump Plaza
Hotel because they were dealing with
laboux T Trump campaign spokeswoman hope
Hicks was asked to comment on the video
saying quote this was obviously a
massive event which took place decades
ago mr. Trump attended many similar
events with thousands of people during
this time period but again laboux T's
daughter says they were there
specifically as Donald Trump's guests
it's another day another live hat and
there's been so many in this campaign
but I would say that the most egregious
claim that he made in terms of knowing
people he didn't was at her
in debate when he said that he lost
hundreds of friends on 9/11 when they
looked into it he couldn't even name one
yeah and that that's probably the most
despicable sort of political pandering
live this is just I didn't know the guy
and he knew the guy and it's just not
doesn't look that good to know this guy
and it goes even further right Jack
O'Donnell who's the former president of
Trump Plaza said actually Trump and
LaBute II did a business deal together
they took a trip together on Trump's
private helicopter they knew each other
they were involved in in horse sales
purchases a whole thing individually not
a huge deal but it's that pattern of
Trump claiming not to know or having
never met various people that he had met
all of whom are really inconvenient to
have met in some way shape or form
obviously 15 plus women accusing Trump
of sexual assault is more disturbing
than him having known a mob connected
guy that he claimed not to know but the
point is this is all a facade and it is
all lies